- Bonjour !
- Bonjour.
Marlène,
décidemment je ne comprend
rien à cette génération.
Comment se fait-il qu'il y ait
personne à nos ateliers de jazz ?
- Bonjour Philippe.
- Bonjour.
Philippe, personellement, je trouve que vos
ateliers de musique sont une très bonne idée.
Vraiment.
Très peu de lycées proposent des initiatives aussi
épanouissantes à leurs élèves.
Alors quel est le problème ?
Le problème, c'est que le jazz
n'a pas de succès chez nos élèves.
Vous n'allez pas encore me parler de "rap", là ?
Philippe, je ne comprend pas ce qui
vous dérange quand on parle de ce style de musique.
Ce n'est pas un style de musique.
Non, Philippe, vous n'êtes pas objectif.
Vous êtes féru de jazz, ok.
Vous aviez même un groupe.
- Un quartet.
- Pardon ?
Ce n'était pas un group, c'est un quartet.
D'accord, un quartet.
Bon, écoutez, même si je fais l'effort
de mettre de côté le fait
que je trouve que le rap, c'est de la merde,
Ça reste une activité qui ne demande aucun travail.
Et vous savez, vous mieux que tout le monde ici
que c'est exactement
l'inverse de ce que je compte leur inculquer.
Eh bien c'est vraiment dommage.
Figurez-vous que je connais un rappeur très talentueux
qui était partant pour intervenir dans notre lycée.
- Qui ça ?
Médine.
Et bien vous direz à ce "Médine"
que nous ne sommes pas intéressés.
On ne peut vraiment pas discuter avec vous.
Ce qui m'étonne,
c'est de découvrir un jeune
comme vous avec des idées de vieux.
Mais Marlène, alors ?
Bon, j'aurais au moins essayé.
N'importe quoi...
Que les élèves n'aient pas conscience des choses,
je peux difficilement leur en vouloir.
Mais quand c'est mes propres collègues
qui sont aveuglés,
là je ne sais pas quoi faire.
Après on est peut-être juste trop fermés ?
Oh ben non !
Tu ne vas pas t'y mettre, toi aussi ?
C'est bon, moi je suis avec toi, hein.
Je me posais juste la question.
Après, un bon petit Gims
de temps en temps, ça ne fait pas de mal.
Tu plaisantes ?
Il n'y a rien de plus pauvre en paroles que ça !
Ne me demandes pas la lune,
j'ai beaucoup mieux pour toi
Non, n'importe qui peut écrire ça.
Pourtant tu ne m'as jamais dit un truc pareil.
- Pardon ?
- Bah ouais,
si c'est si facile, vas-y,
invente-moi un truc du style !
Ben, oui.
Ben...
Tu m'as toujours ébloui.
Un peu comme une lampe.
- "Comme une lampe" ?
- Ouais.
Parce qu'une lampe, ça éblouit ?
Non, c'est justement faible
en terme de luminosité, Philippe.
C'est nul !
Je suis pas...
Je suis pas d'accord.
Ça dépend de la lampe.
Bon allez, bonne nuit.
Elle a fait de moi un homme
Mais maman n'aime pas que je la côtoie
Elle me fait courir après les sommes
Et c'est à cause d'elle que je rentre tard
Elle m'a appris à pas me laisser faire
Tu me cherches, je réponds par le fer
Elle m'as donné des guns et des munitions
et à cause d'elle, j'ai pris du ferme
Pareil pour tous mes frères,
mes sœurs, ma cop'  et ma mère
Putain de merde, c'est trop la merde
Mais comment je vais faire
Ya, ya, ya !
Elle m'a fait rencontrer les guetteurs
M'as mis des claques et balayettes
Je voudrais tellement que le rap n'ai jamais existé.
Tu vas être en retard.
J'ai dormi là ?
Et oui.
Je m'excuse.
Ah, ben. Ça arrive.
Non, mais, de m'être énervé hier,
au sujet du rap.
C'était puéril, voilà.
- Au sujet de quoi ?
- Du rap.
C'est quoi, ça ?
Ben, le rap ?
- Le "rap" ?
- Le style de musique, le rap !
Jamais entendu ça de ma vie.
- Tu te fiches de moi ?
- Ben non !
- On en a parlé hier soir !
- Quoi ?
Le rap !
- Quoi, le rap ?
- Mais, le rap !
- Mais le rap, tu me dis ça,
- ll y a une chaine de télé
- sauf que je sais pas ce que c'est !
- qui en diffuse du matin au soir !
Le rap, voilà !
Oui ben, ça c'est du raï.
Tu me parles du raï ?
Bon, on parlera de raï ce soir.
Allez, faut que j'aille bosser.
Bisou !
Bisou...
Skyraï...
Ça a sonné hein !
En cours, s'il vous plaît.
Bonjour Philippe.
Il faut absolument qu'on parle
du conseil de discipline de jeudi.
Marlène, j'ai une autre urgence.
Ah oui ?
On a parlé de quoi hier ?
De votre passion, le jazz.
Mais encore ?
Je vous ai proposé une connaissance
comme intervenant.
Connaissance qui s'appelle ?
Médine...
Le rappeur !
De quoi ?
Le rappeur qui fait du rap.
Le rappeur !
Je ne vois pas de quoi vous voulez parler.
C'est pas possible.
Bon il faut absolument que
je le rencontre aujourd'hui.
Je peux vous organiser ça,
il n'y a pas de problème.
Merci.
Non mais...
ça va Philippe ?
Oui, oui, ça va aller.
Ça va aller.
Bon et bien,
je vous envoie ses coordonnées.
Ok.
Je vous préviens,
il est souvent en rendez-vous.
Mais vous pouvez toujours tenter.
Ok. Merci beaucoup.
Merci Marlène.
Vous êtes psy en fait.
Oui.
Vous vous attendiez à quoi ?
Pas à ça.
Précisez.
Ça m'aurait rassuré
si vous aviez été un rappeur quoi.
Un rappeur ?
Laissez tomber.
Ne vous mettez pasde barrière, Philippe.
Je ne suis pas dans le jugement.
Allez-y.
En même temps,
au point où j'en suis.
Hier...
j'étais dans un monde...
totalement différent.
Un monde dans lequel le style de musique
dont je vous parle, le rap,
était partout.
Le style le plus populaire du monde.
Et aujourd'hui, je me réveille...
dans un monde où le rap n'existe pas.
Où personne n'en a jamais
entendu parler.
Et comment vous expliquez ça selon vous ?
Je sais pas... enfin...
j'ai souhaité que le rap n'ai jamais existé
parce que je déteste ce style de musique
mais...
Vous devriez être content ?
Oui mais non.
C'est pas mon monde.
Vous savez ce qui vous arrive ?
Ce n'est rien du tout.
Ah bon ?
Ce que vous appelez le rap, c'est ça ?
Oui.
Vous l'avez associé
potentiellement à un traumatisme.
Du coup quand on aura trouvé ensemble...
ce traumatisme...
et bien vous pourrez
retrouver votre monde d'avant...
tout à fait normalement.
Ah bon ?
À quoi ressemble ce style de musique ?
Comme il existe pas,
c'est un peu compliqué à décrire quoi...
Justement, ce qui m'intéresse,
c'est comment vous allez le décrire.
Philippe,
vous devez passer par cette étape.
En fait, ça repose
principalement sur la vitesse.
Ça va beaucoup plus vite que les paroles
d'une chanson classique mais en gardant les rimes.
Très bien.
Montrez-moi.
Bon alors, juste comme
je connais pas de paroles par coeur de chanson,
je vais devoir improviser
et ça risque de pas être incroyable.
D'accord.
Allô ?
Ton téléphone sonne,
Ça résonne dans la cage d'escalier.
Le son monte, sonne,
et résonne dans la nuit.
Car tu as fait le mauvais choix
dans ta vie.
Tu as tout perdu.
Tu n'as rien reçu.
Juste de la rue.
Mue...
Ta peau mue.
Mu... la musique est bonne.
Est-ce que la musique est bonne ?
Oui.
La musique est bonne.
Sonne.
Résonne comme ton téléphone.
Dans la...
Ça rime pas des masses,
c'est assez narratif.
Mais... vous avez compris le...
J'ai... ouais...
les rimes c'est compliqué en fait.
Je pense qu'on aura
un peu plus de travail que prévu.
Pour guérir de ça en tout cas.
Philippe ?
Il faut absolument
qu'on parle du prochain conseil de discipline.
Je vous écoute.
Alors comme vous le savez...
la majorité des enseignants
sont pour l'exclusion définitive.
Ah non. Depuis que je travaille ici,
je n'ai jamais exclu un élève
définitivement et je compte bien
continuer comme ça.
Je sais bien mais c'est la troisième
commission disciplinaire de cet élève.
Les profs sont à bout.
La troisième ?
Mais de qui on parle ?
Non mais...
De Landry N'Guema
De Landry N'Guema ?
Mais c'est un de nos élèves les plus prometteurs.
Non mais vous rigolez ?
Il n'a pas fait un contrôle depuis des mois.
Et il aurait agressé deux de ses profs.
Dans ce monde là, Landry est différent.
Pardon ?
Euh... rien je pensais à autre chose.
Philippe...
je compte vraiment
sur vous sur ce coup là.
La commission a lieu jeudi.
Il faut que vous soyez
prêt à l'exclure définitivement.
Il est où là ?
Il est en permanence.
Il sèche les cours
pour aller en permanence ?
Oui.
- Il écrit.
- Il écrit quoi ?
Je sais pas.
Il écrit mais
ne rend jamais de copie.
Bon, faites-le venir.
Ok.
- Bonjour Landry.
- Bonjour.
Alors, qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Comment ça il se passe quoi ?
Tu sais que tu es sur le point
de te faire renvoyer ?
Et alors ?
Qu'est ce que je m'en fous.
Comment c'est possible
que tu puisses t'en foutre ?
L'école, c'est pas pour moi
et j'ai d'autres problèmes.
De toute façon, vous serez bien content
quand je ne serais plus là.
Qui sera content ?
Vous tous là !
Tous ceux qui me font comprendre
que je ne suis pas à ma place ici.
Évidemment que tu es à ta place ici.
Est-ce que tu réalises
le potentiel que tu as ?
Vous vous foutez de ma gueule ?
Mais non, pas du tout.
Landry, tu es très prometteur.
Hey vas-y, ça fait deux ans
que vous me dîtes le contraire.
Vous voulez que je pète
un câble avant la commission ?
Mais non.
Alors arrêtez de mentir.
Ça va ?
Hmmm...
Je vois bien qu'il y a un truc qui te tracasse.
Y'a un de mes élèves
qui était extrêmement doué un jour...
et qui soudainement,
de manière complètement surnaturelle...
est devenu le pire élève
de mon établissement.
Ah bon ?
Décidément, c'est la journée
des trucs bizarres pour toi.
Comment ça ?
Attends, ce matin tu me parles d'un style
de musique complètement inconnu...
Le rap.
et maintenant tu me parle
d'un élève qui soudainement devient mauvais.
C'est fou quand même.
Mais c'est lié.
À quoi ?
Landry, mon élève...
Hmmm...
il faisait du rap.
Sans le rap,
son comportement s'est déréglé.
Alors c'est fou le bien que le rap
peut faire pour ces jeunes.
Oui.
Et bien le problème est réglé.
Pas tout à fait.
Salut les jeunes.
Ça va ?
Landry, je peux te parler ?
Bougez Monsieur.
Pardon ?
J'ai pas à vous respecter ici,
en plus demain je ne serais plus votre élève.
Justement, à propos de ça,
je pense qu'on peut éviter ton exclusion.
Vas-y, vas-y,
je veux pas parler de ça.
Je sais que tu écris en perm'.
Et je pense que ce que tu écris...
même si je suis pas encore sûr...
c'est peut être du rap.
Allô ?
Ouais.
Vas-y, j'arrive.
Vas-y.
Bon les gars, je bouge.
Non, Landry. Attends !
Landry !
Qu'est-ce que...
Qu'est-ce que vous écoutez
comme musique, vous ?
Mylène Farmer.
Quoi ?
T'entends pas ou quoi ?
Je t'ai dit Mylène Farmer.
Wesh, y'a quoi de marrant là ?
Tu te fous de sa gueule ?
Hey Mylène Farmer,
tu la respectes, hein ?
C'est la seule qui parle
de nous dans ses sons.
Elle est invitée dans aucune émission,
comme nous frère.
Elle parle de vous ?
Samir...
Tout est chaos...
à côté...
Tu crois qu'elle parle de quoi là ?
Tout est chaos à côté.
C'est les bâtiments,
tout est délabré.
C'est le quartier wesh !
Tous mes idéaux : des mots abîmés...
Ça c'est les rêves inatteignables.
Je cherche une âme qui pourra m'aider
C'est dur des trouver des meufs,
et puis vas-y, c'est dur de faire confiance à l'autre.
Je suis d'une génération désenchantée,
désenchantée...
C'est nous la génération désanchantée.
Des mecs de quartiers.
Retiens ça et puis manque plus de respect
à Mylène Farmer, je te le dis direct.
D'accord.
Bah oui.
Bon...
Bonne journée.
Merci hein.
Tous ses profs sont catégoriques.
Donc, je pense qu'il n'y a plus rien à dire.
Nous avons entendu ce que
tes enseignants avaient à dire.
Landry, c'est à toi de t'exprimer.
Non mais j'ai rien à dire.
Non mais t'es sûr ?
T'as vraiment rien à dire ?
Ouais.
Bon et bien maintenant
nous allons procéder à la délibération.
Attendez.
Moi je...
je pense que Landry a des choses à dire justement.
Quoi ?
Je pense que ce qu'il écrit
sans cesse en salle de permanence,
c'est tout ce qu'il ressent
et qu'il n'arrive pas à exprimer.
Je me trompe ?
Je sais pas mais qu'est-ce que
ça va changer de toute façon ?
Et bien je t'offre le moyen de t'exprimer.
Lis tes notes.
Fais-moi confiance.
Je peux savoir ce qui se passe là, Philippe ?
Écoutez-le.
Je sais même pas si je hais le monde,
ou si c'est le monde qui me hais.
On me dit prépare ton futur mais au mot futur,
y'a des putain de guillemets.
Tout part en couille, le cousin a pris perpette,
la daronne oublie plein de têtes,
Y'a des bouts de feuilles sur la f'nêtre
pour pas que le vent me fouette, fouette.
Et vous me prenez la tête
parce que je porte une casquette.
Mais qu'est-ce qui va pas chez vous ?
J'suis bloqué, j'peux pas gé-bou.
Avoir de l'espoir, j'ai beau...
un cocktail de seum, j'ai bu...
Allez, nique sa mère ! Tout va trop vite.
Alors que j'suis qu'en première,
j'vous déconseille d'écouter la conseillère,
et si je cède au CDI, allez tous vous faire.
de toute façon c'est comme d'hab'
vous allez retenir
que mes insultes et mes excès,
J'pourrais être vexé
car j'vous donne accès,
à toutes mes névroses mais à croire
que c'est toujours pas assez.
J'suis pas Rousseau, j'écris pas comme Hugo,
J'écris pas comme Zola, j'écris pas comme Voltaire,
j'me passe de vos commentaires
et les vôtres j'veux pas les faire.
J'ai la haine contre tous ces profs qui me contraignent,
qui gâchent mon potentiel,
veulent m'voir en bas de l'échelle,
moi j'en garde des séquelles.
C'est un appel à l'aide, ouais.
Un appel à l'aide.
Merci Landry.
Je crois qu'on va délibérer maintenant.